i was very keen on
really fleshing out superman's
early stages of his journey first we had
man of steel and then we went quite a
bit darker with batman v superman and if
he were to uh succumb to the anti-life
equation and become bad superman i
really wanted to make sure that we saw
the hero superman and we saw this the
true symbol of hope that the beacon of
light before we went down the path of
darkness and then redemption and still
something that i am very keen to flesh
out
man of steel
the
wonderful thing about man of steel and
what snyder and nolan and and i wanted
to do with with superman
was create
a superman who was accessible in the
sense that
what would
we do if we lived in a world where we
had to keep every single aspect of
ourselves
hidden
and we couldn't really truly interact
with people and how would that affect us
especially when you have that scene with
kevin costner who's saying look don't
don't reveal yourself the world is not
ready for you yet and it'll only only be
a bad thing
clark does follow that that advice at
first but then realizes that's not the
way to go and that he must do what he
must do regardless of that advice and
that was the beautiful bit is that
even though
he has restrained himself and lived this
life of
of of loneliness essentially he's still
willing to step out of the shadows and
become the hero despite the fact that
it's going to have a negative impact on
his life and that i think is the aspect
of that symbol of hope it's he's
representing everything that is good
about mankind despite the fact that
mankind may not be good to him
don't do this
never
[Music]
at the end of man of steel it was set up
so wonderfully to to begin that journey
because he had had his first outing
against the last member surviving over
his species and had to kill him and that
is going to inform a lot of who he
becomes the terrible destruction of
metropolis where he's fighting a someone
who has the same powers of him but
actually has training he barely makes it
out of that thing alive and so what
lessons has he learned he definitely
isn't going to kill anymore and he's
definitely going to make sure that
population centers are completely
removed from the equation because now
he's experienced it and now he's
thinking about it and so we get those
steps towards building that that
incredible
wise version of superman rather than the
you know still wet behind the ears kind
the witcher
the life of an actor can be very
isolated i'm i'm i tend to be a
reasonably private person and so when it
comes to playing geralt i was no
stranger to the idea of being the the
solo nomad uh like traveller and going
from place to place that's something
i've been doing for
21 years now and so that aspect of
geralt was definitely easier to tap into
that's not how it happened
where's your newfound respect
respect doesn't make history
toss a coin to your
[Music]
i think with with season two
of the witcher
my focus
mainly lay with
with making sure that
the geralt orivia from the books was
really shining through in my performance
in the show when i say run
you run
when i say hide i have to stay
you hide
run in season one
there was a deliberate choice of mine to
be
less verbose because i didn't have the
luxury of the show being dedicated
purely to geralt and so you don't have
that swathes of nuance and complex
dialogue which you have in the books and
so i thought okay how do i reflect
geralt's intelligence and his wisdom and
i figured if i actually do the man who
listens more and watches more and
sometimes for some light comedic moments
makes a judgmental noise or two when
someone's finished waffling or
pontificating then it might represent
the character a little better the
advantage of going into season two is
that i actually wanted to make sure that
that book geralt shined through a bit
more especially now that we have him in
a personal environment he's with cyrilla
who becomes his ward and ultimately a
daughter-like figure to him and then
we're with his his witcher kin and and
his father like figaro and vesemir and
so at that stage he doesn't have to have
the walls up he doesn't have to be so
closed off and i wanted to really reach
into it and just make sure that he had a
more expanded vocabulary and that he
sounded more intelligent and that he
came across as someone who had the
wisdom of between 70 and 90 years for me
that was the real focal point of of
season two i didn't i don't think i
found any moments where i was like aha i
found a little deeper level to geralt it
was more about making sure that that
part of the books lived in the show
mission impossible fallout
that was i mean firstly an amazing movie
to work on uh such a good fortune to
work with the likes of chris mcquarrie
and tom cruise and and everyone on that
it was
rob hardy everyone they're the dp that
is and
i was
counting my lucky stars every day that's
how this is about sure it is
i know you don't want me on this detail
but let's face it
if you'd made the hard choice in berlin
i wouldn't be here if you hadn't gone
down your syndicate agent they sent you
to find i wouldn't be here
that's right i know all about you
you're why we don't have a living
witness who can identify john mark or
the apostles
if you have a problem with my methods
you can always stay behind
your mission should you choose
to accept it isn't that the thing
some of the days that i was not quite
counting as many lucky stars as others
was the helicopter sequence
now i loved it i thought it was a lot of
fun but
because i'm in a helicopter with the
doors open
above the mountains of new zealand
in winter it's particularly cold it took
two three weeks maybe four weeks to
shoot that and so that's four weeks of
me
hanging outside a helicopter with my
head in the wind and i'm firing real
blanks and so it's not it's not like cgi
stuff added
[Music]
i'm having blank residue flying
everywhere i can't hear anything because
my headset's not working i'm just
waiting for the pilot to scream
something and give a signal i'm like i
think he means rolling we're moving so
maybe he means rolling i'm just going to
stick my head out the window and and
start acting and maybe we're catching
something that was probably
the most difficult bit but at the same
time the most thrilling because
you're in a scene with
an actor and a producer as dedicated as
tom cruise who's learned how to stunt
fly a helicopter in the mountains which
is a very different thing mountains are
very difficult for helicopters and you
can see the whites of his eyes in the
helicopter behind you as you're being
chased you're pretending to fire this
huge machine gun at him it's everyone's
so happy at the end of each day and it's
genuinely exciting and then at the end
of each day i'm sitting on the skid of
this helicopter looking out across the
ocean off new zealand above a glacier
and people don't get to do that that was
something which is uh you know once in a
lifetime experience and
as much as it was
a touch on the chilly side it was an
experience which i i would not change
for anything
enough games i'll take you out of here
where's hunt
he's gone to the meeting with a copy of
you calm down
call me apostles
i have no way of contacting them for
their safety and mine
what i do have is an extraction team
with satellite overwatch in a
pre-arranged rendezvous i'll know as
soon as we leave the building
enola homes
the funny thing about approaching
characters with as long a history as say
sherlock holmes
is that i don't approach it deliberately
with the intention to make it my own i
look at how it's been played before and
i had the very good fortune of working
with harry bradbeer
and the character has been done so well
before
and it's all the
the classic uh
direct adaptations of the source
material have been done so wonderfully
that it actually allowed me room to to
not necessarily do things precisely as
the books have done before
i have never seen such a range of
romances in my life
it's after turning into newspapers
what heavens are you looking for
why might you be interested in the
personals you're going quite mad i have
a right to be mad at a place like this
i was forced into calligraphy as a child
ah
hated it but there's really a case where
someone's handwriting doesn't tell me
something i need to know
and what might i learn from deportment
the way a person stands may disguise
who they are because this is a story
about
anola and sherlock is a player within
that story
i wanted to make sure that it was
supporting a nola story more than
anything else and to play sherlock in
the way i played it was that was the
intention always it was always to make
sure that
anola was the focus and that it was a
a character who
would do nothing but highlight all of a
nola's wonderfully positive traits and
we could tie back little family ties
here and there similarities because
ultimately nola and sherlock become come
quite a pair because they do have some
some real similarities in there
and nola
my god
look at you
you're in such a mess
where's your hat in your gloves
well i have a hat just makes the head
itch and i have no gloves
she has no gloves clearly not my dropped
the man from uncle
guy richie and i had plenty of
conversations before we started shooting
man from uncle and the wonderful thing
about guy is that he is very much a
creator he's very much a collaborator
and so we would literally sit in his
house and talk through scenes and throw
ideas around and and it was always an
open playing field and he was very
honest he'd say that's a terrible idea
we're never doing that or he would say
you know what that's way better than my
idea and i'm kind of embarrassed uh so
let's put that in or he'd come back we'd
come back the next day and say you know
what i said it was a terrible idea i've
thought about it it's not a terrible
idea it's actually a really good idea we
would work and manipulate this character
and we'd find the best way of doing
things and so
as much as robert vaughan did an amazing
job it was we wanted to make this this
our own and and guy has such a
particular style and he's such a
wonderful director to work with i felt
like i was in very very safe hands there
and so no matter what we did it was
going to be he was going to create
something cool and we were going to do
it together
i'll let you tag along but it's in and
out no mess so nobody knows we've been
here and we both forget about in the
morning
[Music]
what is it
super hard and boron sharpened with a
co2 laser
co2 laser
immortals
it wasn't as challenging as as one may
think working on a green screen of
course tarzan was very generous and he
had lots of artwork to show us and would
say like this is this is what you're
looking at basically if we were looking
off
a cliff top into an expanse beyond
[Applause]
it definitely was a great introduction
because
later in my career i ended up working in
pure green screen rooms and that's a bit
uh discombobulating when it came to
immortals it was a good warm-up for the
rest of it
the tudors
while playing charles brandon i had
the really good fortune of the creator
of the show and the writer being michael
hurst michael hurst is very very
talented and
would always dive and delve deep into
the history of all these characters to
find the most interesting titbits and
and sometimes he would combine
characters otherwise would there be too
many mary's margarets and elizabeth's to
to kind of make sense of a tv show it's
really hard to find
material on charles brand and i've
looked and he said yeah charles brown is
a tough one to find to find stuff on and
so he took what little he had and what
little you could find in history and
really expanded upon it it was such a
pleasure having him write that character
because he was
it was almost like he was bringing the
character
to life i gave michael a gift
at the end of the show
saying if charles brandon were alive he
would today he would thank you
grace
what do you want only to pass on his
majesty's love
he appreciates the role you will play at
my lord buckingham's trial
and draw the care you have for his
majesty's well-being
he also sends you this
so for me it was using what came off the
page really it was one of those
pleasurable experiences of not having to
really work against what's on the page
or build it up into something else
michael had done so much of the work
there
the count of monte cristo
i was 17 years old
playing 16 which at the time was a big
difference obviously but for anyone our
age now not so much
several of my friends are going to roam
twigs during carnival
i'd like to accompany them
and no chaperones i'm very only 15.
almost 16.
make my birthday present father i was in
boarding school in england i met with
priscilla john who was a casting
director she was so supportive and she
really sort of helped help me get the
role really when it came to meeting with
the director kevin reynolds it was a
huge event for me because i was
shortlisted for this movie at 17 years
old that's a massive deal especially if
you want to become an actor and you
haven't really seen the outside world
that much you haven't been around london
all the time because i'm a kid from
jersey it's a tiny island in in between
england and france and when i'm not in
jersey i'm in the walls of my boarding
school and so to have this the world
kind of reach in and start investigating
who i was was a very very exciting thing
[Music]
[Applause]
and then i had to have the conversation
with my parents about the last year of
my schooling and i said well what do i
do and they said look you've always
wanted to become an actor you know go
for it see what happens if all falls
apart if it fails you can go back to
school you can get your a levels but
otherwise run with the ball and so i did
and here i am now the only way one can
play a character who is so intelligent
that he can dissect every other
character before they have a chance to
speak is a fantastic writer it's all up
to the right it's all up to the director
an actor can do whatever they want but
if it's not on the page and it's not in
the scene already and it's not and then
the director isn't be able to able to
pick it up and the editor isn't able to
put it together then there's no hope for
that characters look that intelligent
and so it's all down to the amazing
ability of jack thorne harry bradbeer
and the editors